hello my name is zai Segev I'll be
talking about the power of typesetting
and I will give a brief introduction
into some of the principles that go into
formatting inputs and outputs and the
Wolfram language and how we can make
that to make interfaces more aesthetic
and also more usable so what is
typesetting we can mean a few different
things by by that there's front-end
typesetting which sometimes is called
box rendering 2d editing this is the
visual appearance of box expressions
creation of modification of them in
response to user actions so if you don't
already know at your notebook that you
see is a Wolfram language expression in
a particular subset called the box
explain --which and so the front-end
takes that notebook converts those
expressions into beautiful things which
you see like square roots and fractions
and all that good stuff then there is
kernel typesetting also called output
typesetting output formatting this is
the conversion of the Wolfram language
expressions to the Box language for
transmission to the front-end so when
you type something in well actually I
should say that next and then there's
kernel on typesetting which is also
called input typesetting or box
interpretation this is the conversion of
box expression sent by the front-end
into normal expressions to be evaluated
by the kernel so you type something into
your notebook and something gets created
there and you can see the word box so
this is a box expression and when you
hit shift enter that get that box
expression gets sent to the kernel the
kernel turns that box expression into
the actual input that you mean to
evaluate it evaluates that input then it
converts the result back to the box
expression and it transmitted that box
expression for the front end to insert
into your notebook and then
display this talk will be primarily
about Colonel typesetting
the this stage of taking the output and
converting it into something pretty I
have no control over front-end
typesetting other than pestering the
people in this room who do have control
over it and every now and then they make
me go away by actually doing what I'm
pissing them
I also do a lot of Colonel on
typesetting but this talk is not so much
about that although I'm happy to answer
questions about that so some related
talks the typesetting workshop by a
Jason Harris will be here next it'll
talk some more about some of the
front-end aspects but also the
typesetting and untyped setting stages
what's new in calculus and algebra if
you're interested in that aspect of the
talk that'll be this afternoon by the
vendor and Adam if you care a great deal
about how things look and the exact
number of pixels between the fraction
line and the square root underneath it
then go to the math typesetting
roundtable which is tomorrow at 1:00
p.m. so that's really a front-end
typesetting
business Lou will be talking about some
related aspects to output formatting
related to this talk and then for more
about limits which will feature premium
prominently in this talk but primarily
their appearance
not so much all the functionality
that'll be tomorrow at 4:30 and I shall
briefly mention but not go into the
details of the init code that does not
appear in this talk I should mention
with one very small exception everything
that I'm going to show you is in 11 - so
you should expect to see this and be
able to play with it
so some principles of output formatting
output formatting is supposed to
faithfully represent the results for
later use as input so that means if you
take the output paste it into an input
cell and reevaluate it you should get
the same thing you got as above so that
in particular means it can't leak it
can't somehow change evaluate part of
the expression and change it one of the
things we try to do and you should also
try to do is to restrict formatting to
valid expressions this helps reduce
leaks it also makes it sort of easy to
tell what's you know some random
expression which happens to have had
sparse array but isn't really a sparse
array as opposed to an actual
honest-to-goodness sparse array it needs
to be fast people get very annoyed if
their computation takes point 1 seconds
but then they have to wait 15 minutes
for the result to be formatted not that
anybody has ever reported a bug against
me to that effect
also avoid messages you want users to
know that the messages they see come
from the code they wrote not from your
random formatting code so those are some
basics ideas you want to keep in mind so
we have two main output formats in
notebook standard format traditional
form standard form wants to be
unambiguous to the extent that it's
possible it should be typable and
editable right you should be able to
just type it in using keyboard shortcuts
if necessary and edit it there are some
exceptions like graphics right they
format as things you see because they're
visual things controls right it would be
not very useful if a slider formatted as
the input form of the slider but not as
an actual slider you can sly and we try
to be sort of as close as possible to
the underlying structure
by contrast we have traditional form
which would look traditional that can
mean different things not everything has
a sort of traditional form but sort of
you know to the extent that there's
mathy traditional appearance for
something that's what we try to
customize what we try to target we try
to allow for some costume customization
which I'm going to be talking about and
in the service of these couple of
important goals we might sacrifice the
type ability we might hide structure or
give different expressions similar or
identical appearance so let's illustrate
those differences so here I have what
looks like two column matrices with a
and B in them and so they should be
equal to each other and I evaluate them
and I get false and here I have three
things which I'm claiming they're not
equal to each other they're all
different from each other even though
they all look pretty identical but in
fact these are three different things
and here I have M men versus equal to M
inverse
surely that one must give true and yet
it does not so what's actually going on
here so the first input is actually the
matrix a B and binomial of a B if I had
not cleverly moved my mouse in order to
hide this fact you could have seen that
there's this may be too small to read in
from the screen but there's a little
tooltip there which says this is a
binomial whereas if you just sort of go
over here
no tooltip on the other hand with theta
we have one just plain theta of T then
we have heavy site theta then we have
unit step and the unit step and the
heavy site theta have little tooltips
this random theta of T that I typed in
does not have the tooltip let me point
out that these two left
and sides you can just type in I mean I
quite literally did just open open some
parentheses create a row matrix type a B
and if this were traditional form cell
this would be interpreted as the list I
guess even in standard form this is
interpreted as a list although it
wouldn't it doesn't format like that by
default whereas in traditional form it
formats using the parentheses
whereas this Heaviside theta theta of t
is not so easy to type in and this last
one well they're both inverses but they
differ in options and because the these
both say inverse so you know it's an
inverse but you don't really know that
these are two different and inverses
which is slightly unfortunate but on the
other hand if you're really looking to
you know make a nicely formatted output
that's probably bad for the best
yes
yes yes on Windows and Linux that would
be ctrl shift and and control shift T so
I don't know how we got from standard to
n maybe that's normal appearance the T
is pretty easy to figure out
so those are two useful shortcuts oh yes
often time so so for the shortcut is
command shift and converts so you select
the cell by clicking on the cell bracket
and you hit shift command and or ctrl
shift and if you're on Windows and Linux
and it converts it to standard form and
if you hit command shift T or control
shift T and converts it to traditional
form okay all right so so what are some
recent advances so the number domains
and we are actually seven but I'm going
to focus on for the four familiar once
integers rational reels and complexes
before 11 - the only formatted and
traditional form they actually didn't
have any tooltips to allow to allow you
to distinguish them and they had no
customization and so this cell here I
put in a secret option to make it use
one of my older Mathematica is to
evaluate so this is evaluated in 11 1 1
and you see that in standard form
they just formatted as their names but
in traditional form you got these you
know traditional domain notation so in
11 - they format in both forms they now
have tooltips and they're customizable
so if I were to evaluate this example we
see that they formatted in in both forms
and if I hover over them there's a
little tooltip which if you're really
close to the board you can tell says
complexes
all right so our first customization
example so this customizing involves
learning a little bit of the Box
language or a lot depending on how much
customization you want to do but this is
a very simple example if we call make
boxes which is the function the kernel
uses to turn its output into the box
language then we see that this creates a
template box named reals
I'll talk a little bit about that empty
list in a bit so if we want to customize
this we can go to format menu and say
edit style sheet and we can create a new
style called reals and then so that's
down here and let me increase the
magnification so you can actually read
something
so there's reals and that so looks a bit
small we will make it that's a bit
bigger reals and then you unform at the
cell I did that using command shift e or
ctrl shift e on windows and linux you
could also have done that using cell
show expression is how you do it from
the menu
now you will paste in the following code
template box options goes to the list
and display function and here I'm going
to change it from a double struck our to
a gothic R so I'm going to copy this
code going to go to this menu and going
to insert this code comma and now when I
reformat this cell then you see the R
change from a double struck to gothic so
let me do that well I guess I'd have to
delete it so if I delete it it goes away
if I paste it back in it becomes gothic
again now because this process is a
little bit tedious I
actually in that in it code which I
didn't show you I created two functions
which do this so if I clear the
formatting and why did that not work my
step not working
okay that's slightly oh it was working
it was just slow for somebody is in okay
so here I have a slightly fancier
version where I disabled syntax
colouring and I forced the font family
too so it always has uniform appearance
no matter where you stick it in all
right
so oh and I guess I didn't show off
though the one new so we have these new
key input shortcuts we mentioned and one
of the nice new features in 11:3 is that
these shortcuts complete so shortcuts
not just for characters but also for
formatted expressions so I can select
int and voila there's my my integers
okay limits in standard form okay so in
11 - limit has been upgraded and it has
new friends max limit and min limit
discrete limit and discrete versions
thereof and standard formed the format
using new limit operators so we have
nested limits which are sort of iterated
limits we have multivariate limits so
how do you enter these guys well you use
the new limit characters you enter
either subscript or under script if you
know what limits positioning is that
it'll base limits positioning and you
can use from above or from below in sort
of the obvious way
so here I have a pre-formatted example I
evaluate that that used to return
infinity now it returns indeterminate
because the two-sided limit is now the
default so the following is sort of an
equivalent input but to illustrate I can
type in Lim I can hit control for to
enter an under script you can say X goes
to zero I can select that rule and hit
control four again and now I can insert
complexes and now I can type in 1 over X
and now I will get a different answer
I'll get complex infinity because we're
taking a limit in the complex plane and
and so we you know 1 over X maps to 0 to
the point at infinity now that's a limit
from above because I put in a
superscript and can also lips do X goes
to 0 and put in a superscript at minus
and take 1 the limit of 1 over X and now
I get minus infinity ok I'm running low
on time alright so now you could type
into discrete limits by hand but that
gets to be a little bit tedious so we
created again these shortcuts for
example DLM for discrete limit and then
you take the limit as n goes to infinity
over the integers of sign event that
doesn't exist but the max limit and min
limit do exist they have a little note
in some situations that will not work
for you I'm going to skip that if you've
upgraded from previous versions
I explained how to fix that if these
shortcuts don't show up for you in that
little note there
okay so briefly let us compare standard
form and traditional form so here's our
this is the standard form appearance we
had now you'll notice that in
traditional form we don't have these
under scripted zis say for the discrete
limits because I thought people would
would kill me if they if they saw this
non-standard Z in the output although
surprisingly Paul somebody complained
about this we can talk about that later
so more so as comparing the standard
form and traditional form clearly the
the traditional form is more traditional
this isn't something you can really type
in I haven't really shown that but it's
more customizable and that's a common
trade off so I will the basic process is
is basically the same as what we did
before we first look at the boxes and
here I just have a simplified input and
we see that it creates a template box
called discrete limit then you have the
arguments and you know this or at least
pieces of the arguments appearing in
different slots here in in the list and
these positions in the list are things
you need to reference when you create
the display function so I'm going to
create a new style called discrete max
limit and
[Music]
I will create a row box so this is
getting a little bit technical if you
know the box language it's pretty
straightforward but I'm going to now
instead of using an over line limb for
limb soup I'm going to use limb soup so
we want an under script box then we want
it with and then the second argument the
X arrow third argument the a and then
after the under script box we want the
first argument F and so we do that and
if we go up here then nothing has
happened for some reason there we go and
now this over line thing has become a
lemon soup and similarly we could do the
same process for the limb int and we get
we get lemons now with I'm really don't
have time to go through this but I will
just briefly mention with with the
continuous versions it's more
complicated rather than X limit there's
something called maxilla nat - argh and
some and that's because you have
different directions so in fact there
are three different types there's max
limit - argh there's max limit with
tooltip and there's max limit with the
superscript and I will let you peruse to
take home recipes from the comfort of
your own home if you want sort of very
fancy basically I show how to convert
everything to a nicely formatted limb
suplements and also how to use up arrow
down arrow rather than a super scripted
plus and superscripted - for limits from
above and limits from below there's also
a little technical note on limit that
you should read if you want to customize
the appearance of limit although I don't
expect that to be
super common desire ok summary boxes in
the minute and a half I have left so
briefly summary boxes have a different
set of trade-offs because they fill a
different need they're used for cases
where the full form is for some reason
not what we want to see so it might be
too big it might represent an external
object or it might be a case where we're
optimizing for performance so you want
to avoid seeing the complete expression
we try to visualize the data where
possible and we're going to sacrifice
any editability to achieve these goals
so to illustrate what I mean by this I
will time series so you'll notice that
this icon here is sort of blueish and
pretty and that indicates that this is a
visualization of actual data this random
random 25 numbers I generated here
whereas this one is a grey all grey
that means this is sort of a generic
icon because it couldn't create a
visualization because how do you plot
the string a the string B and the string
C so one of the new features in 11 2 so
sparse array used to be one of these
outputs which you couldn't use as input
because we didn't want to sacrifice
performance to embed the whole big
sparse array into a notebook so we've
come up with this new system where for
small inputs we do put it in so I can
copy this sparse array out and insert it
into a new cell and it evaluates for big
ones you we don't embed it but we now
have a notebook button that you can
insert the full expression into the
notebook if you so desire so you've done
a long computation it gives you some
answer you want to save this for later
results you press that button now if
each one of these sparse arrays is you
know 50 megabyte
in size you may not want to do that at
every single step but certainly you know
for the last one you probably want to
save your results and just brief
illustration this will be really hard to
see but one compiled function here has
WV m for Wolfram virtual machine and the
other icon has C to indicate one was
compiled to C one was compiled to the
Wolfram virtual machine so I am over
time so I will just briefly yes that you
can again peruse the summary box
creation guide if you want to create
your own typesetting allows input and
output in natural forms there are
various trade offs you need to balance
but ultimately the goal is not just to
look beautiful although that's always
nice but to make something usable for
the task at hand and I would like to
briefly acknowledge two teams here two
symbolic steam of which I am the
multicolored sheep of the family that
makes pretty things and the typesetting
team who has taught me many things over
the years to help me make the Symbolics
code more more pretty and I will just
briefly list the talks if you are
interested in them I will be available
for now for a bit and also at one
o'clock I'll be downstairs indecent and
the symbolic smooth so feel free to come
by and ask me any advanced questions you
would like that's me thank you
you